all right well thank you all for coming
I appreciate it what I'm going to talk
about is our project to increase the
number of students in horticulture
programs now there's a number of authors
on this and we're gonna see in a slider
to where these folks all fit in it truly
has been a very big project and a lot of
folks have been involved with it as
you're gonna see here in a bit um so how
did it all get started I'm gonna do just
a little bit on on what got us to the
point we're at today and it really in a
lot of ways is like the perfect movie
theme you know where these movies where
they've got one set of characters and
there's a little bit of on that and then
they bring in another set of characters
and then a third set of characters and
you know eventually all three sets of
characters are gonna interact but you're
not quite sure when that's going to
happen well that's kind of what was
happening here Mary Meyer was president
of the AHS and she was very focused on
what we call plant blindness which is
where people or plants are all around us
I mean we were eating them you know with
the fruit salad but yet people aren't
aware of them as plants people just
don't pay attention to the plants that
are all around us and she was focusing
on that for her presidency for a SHS
about the same time Doug Needham and
Paul Redmond at Longwood Gardens had
been watching with interest what they
were all horticultural society was doing
now the United Kingdom is probably one
of the areas in the world that is most
into horticulture okay and yet they were
seeing declines in awareness and
interest in horticulture there and they
got very concerned about it so they
commissioned a study and a a project to
increase horticulture called
horticultural matters so Doug and Paul
we're seeing this seeing the success of
this and thinking we needed something
similar here in the United States and at
the same time as all that myself and the
horticultural administrators we meet
annually in one of the year
we actually met here Marvin Pritz hosted
the meeting and what became very clear
is that for a number of us we were
losing ground in terms of students in
horticulture okay so that was one issue
but also it was becoming pretty clear
from the number of emails I was getting
that industry government agencies were
needing horticultural employees okay so
with that we we we did a real quick
survey and I'm not going to show you all
of it but just two at the main point
here the number of undergraduates in
your program has increased greatly or
slightly so around 20 percent stayed the
same around a little over a third and
then the key point there over 40 percent
had either a slight or a major decrease
in the numbers of students now this is
one of those surveys that's good news
and bad news the bad news was yes a lot
of programs were going down but the good
news that gave us hope was up here some
of the schools were going up so what
were they doing how are they doing how
are they presenting the programs and as
we talk to some of those schools it
became clear that we could this was an
issue we could change if we focused on
it so a group of us came together we
were called though we called ourselves
the steering committee for a while three
folks from Longwood Gardens Doug Needham
Brian trader and Marnie Connolly and
then from the American side
horticultural science myself Mary Meyer
Mike Neff Mike Neff is the executive
director of a SHS and I came in a couple
years later as incoming president and
president of aho so we all got together
and we put together a white paper
basically this was our thoughts on what
the issue was and what we thought we
needed to do about it and we had three
very big goals first one improve public
perceptions of horticulture increase the
number of horticulture students in two
and four-year programs
and there was a number of actions we
thought we needed to do there and then
ultimately increasing the number of well
trained horticultural employees okay
first one and the third one these are
very big ideas with our white paper in
hand we talked to other organizations
and we found a very receptive audience
this first group here these are the
signing partners they agreed to support
the initiative in a big way okay and
this number 2013 is when we got them
lined up and then over a hundred and
fifty others said they were very
supportive and would try to support it
in terms of financial and otherwise and
that was universities public gardens
horticultural organizations so that
happened very quickly and it brought a
lot of people together now a lot of
organizations had been concerned about
this some hadn't started on working on
it
others had okay one of our principles
right from the very beginning was not to
duplicate what other people were doing
but try to draw it all together it
became clear this was quickly becoming
bigger than the steering committee could
handle so we brought in some help and we
put out a call for proposals and
fleischman-hillard and scholastic
put in the winning bid and the they were
what they were going to do was help us
with the research the marketing and the
education now we certainly are all
familiar with research but the social
science stuff was a little bit outside
of our bailiwick okay so that's the
introduction on how we got here so let
me show you where we're at now I'm gonna
start first with some of the
organizational things then I'll get to
some of the research we have three
entities the national leadership cabinet
which is co-chaired by Anna ball and
Paul Redmond from Longwood Gardens this
group is fundraising is a big part of
what they're doing
spreading the message to other groups
okay
providing leadership for it
and we're the advisory council I'll show
you the list here in a minute
Charlie Hall and Sarah Cathcart are the
co-chairs of it this involves a lot of
the people from the various
organizations that we had been working
with okay the intent this group is
really to help with the day-to-day
matters of the initiative and spreading
the word back to the various
organizations and one of the great
things we did fairly well about a year
and a half ago it's just made all the
difference in the world is by that point
we had raised enough funds and we were
able to hire an executive director and
Susan Yoder
you get a chance to meet her I hope you
do she's a force of nature and she has
just been doing a lot of great stuff she
came with a lot of experience from other
associations and has really made this
what it is totally coincidental surname
Yoder yeah yeah no relation that we're
aware of to the Yoder mums No yeah
pretty cool in it yeah all right so I'm
not gonna go through these names but
here's the list of the folks that are on
the leadership cabinet and again Anna
ball I think many of you know the name
Anna ball and then Paul Redmond
executive director of Longwood Gardens
and then this Advisory Council now very
long and I know the print is pretty
small but you see a lot of a broad range
of associations companies and various
organizations and individuals coming
together and this is a very dynamic
group the next meeting the next
organizational meeting will be here in
Obion Longwood in February and when this
groups tickets together
lots of great ideas lots of energies and
they've really been getting a lot done
financial support one of the things we
did very early on was we went to the
universities with with horticulture and
asked them to donate we asked them to
donate a very specific amount of money
four thousand nine hundred and ninety
five dollars per year for three years
why four thousand nine hundred and
ninety five dollars
big traffic I don't know it's most
schools 5,000 and up you have to go
through bid oh and a lot of schools did
Cornell being one of them very quickly
stepped up and that money was very
helpful for two reasons one is it got it
started in two when we went to industry
they were very pleased to see that
academics were stepping up to support an
issue that affected academics quite a
bit and that had a big effect I know
that several the companies when they
found out how many universities were
supporting it and what they were doing
and they knew they knew how slim most of
the university budgets were and not all
the universities were able to provide
the close to five thousand but a number
of them were it really made a difference
in terms of getting support from from
the industry and you can see we've got
quite a donor list now okay so since
then we've refined things and I will say
actually Susan Yoder and the crew ever
find things into two main goals changed
the perception of horticulture by
increasing public awareness of the
positive and diverse attributes of the
profession and second was the increased
capacity in horticulture through a
perception shift that gets people to
view horticulture as a viable career
okay alright so what we're looking at is
we want to see a world where everyone
understands and values the importance of
plants and the people who work in the
art science technology and business of
horticulture where parents are always
key and educators encourage horticulture
as a career but not shy away from it
where horticulture is viewed as a vital
viable and diverse career path and where
we build a stronger pipeline of talent
to bolster our industry okay so that in
a sense is the mission of seed your
future all right
so now let's get into some of the
details research you know not
surprisingly this is something that
involves academia so of course research
was going to be at the core of this and
there's three phases of research the
first one was internal to the industry
and I will say that each of these phases
could very easily be a talk in and of
themselves but I'm gonna condense it
down quite a bit just gonna hit a few
highlights alright so the first one was
internal the industry the second one was
focusing on the general public and the
third focused on middle school teachers
parents educators okay so in the first
part here the research consisted of
informal interviews literally
fleischman-hillard with convene groups
and talk to people focus groups and then
a formal online survey of around 500
respondents okay so I'm just going to
hit a couple of the points here why is
horticulture important and I know I'm
speaking to the choir here so this is
should not come as any big surprise
reverse preserves diversity ensures life
you know all the aspects of horticulture
I mean we've had horticulture of the
food horticulture in terms of the
environment horticulture in terms of our
of about the internal and the external
environment provides food helps feed the
world enhances life and beauty ecosystem
restoration and sustainability okay so
these were all some of the responses
that we got what fleischman-hillard did
is they summarized and categorized a lot
of their responses so what are some of
the challenges lack of awareness and
understanding okay we're going to get to
one of the key elements of awareness of
horticulture here in a bit but a lot of
people just really don't have a good
understanding I think back to when I was
a an undergraduate and people would ask
me what's my major and I would say
horticulture either got a blank look or
something like that has something to do
with corn right you know that was about
as far as folks got even back then
skilled labor shortage just came up a
lot from industry and government in
particular shrinking university programs
we've talked about that already
consolidation of degree
programs and then of course lack of
funding on the academic side so why do
we as horticulturists recommend careers
okay why would we encourage somebody
else to do it in the various aspects of
horticulture I know it's kind of small
print there but rewarding okay
time and time again that's what came up
28% diversity variety range of careers
available okay I think about my own
careers at zigged and zagged
okay ability to work outside working
with nature this will come up a lot
nature environment with a lot of
students good for the community helping
others impact the world environment
impact is another word that showed up a
lot and we're gonna see that at various
points through here with all the good
there's a bad gosh what did people look
low pay 59% all the rests kind of right
down there on that is something we're
aware of and we're working on we think
actually the perception of low pay is
probably greater than the low pay
actually is with the exception of
graduate students as way so I will start
with that following up on dinner last
night
okay so switching gears here gone to
Phase two this is the general public
asking them about awareness of
horticulture in attitudes having to do
with horticulture okay part of this
research people were given various
phrases and they were asked to react to
how strongly they agreed with or
disagreed with these phrases now there's
a number of them and for the sake of
time I'm just going to show you one here
horticulture is essential to our food
water and environment only 34 percent of
18 to 34 year olds strongly agreed with
this on the surface okay that's a third
that's not bad
but think about what that saying food
only a third of folks thought that
horticulture was essential for food okay
and you think about what you eat in a
normal day you know the row crops
agronomy provides the bulk of our
calories but really it's the
horticulture that provides a lot of the
taste it provides a lot of the
phytonutrients okay and how critical
horticulture is to what we eat and yet
only about a third made that connection
so that's why that was pretty
significant um marry familiarity with
horticulture in general unless is very
broadly defined and this is going to be
important for later it tended to be a
little bit more better with older folks
35 years and older a little higher with
Caucasian the wealthier they were more
aware of horticulture college degree
more aware of horticulture although not
significally significant the younger the
less likely people were to be aware of
horticulture and again the researchers
in this case we're taking a very broad
definition of horticulture if they
mentioned just anything in I could
remotely be connected they counted it as
aware okay but when we flip it around
when you tell people what is involved
with horticulture they get very very
positive in fact I'm going to step back
just a little bit when we were
interviewing firms to do the marketing
and the research fleischman-hillard had
done a quick survey to get ready for
their presentation and they said they at
that time had not worked with an issue
or the basics were so positive okay
because some of these firms work with
you know companies that are trying to
resurrect their image or you know
professionals that are trying to raise
their L their image they said no this
one they were excited about this one
because the basics were there everybody
likes horticulture they just don't know
it's horticulture Oh
now getting to the Phase three parts
here consistent of online surveys part
of this was two reasons one is to get
information and two was to get an idea
of what the the populations view of
horticulture was the next phase is going
to be trying to change that and so if
you want to change something and you
want to assess it you want to have
numbers to compare it with so the idea
was to find out what are the baseline so
as we go forward hopefully will effect a
change and carrot 7th 8th to 9th graders
a thousand a thousand parents five
hundred teachers and two hundred
guidance counselors that's the number of
people that participated in the online
surveys ok the slide deck that they sent
us for this part was over 80 slides so
I'm just gonna pick a couple all right
um remember this is seventh eighth and
ninth graders already almost a third
want to get a bachelor's degree in a
quarter of oh my masters or a PhD now I
don't know about you but when I was a
ninth grader I had not a clue I mean I
was still I'm sure I was thinking about
going to college at that time but yet a
quarter of students are already thinking
that they're gonna get a masters or a
doctorate so they're already thinking
about stuff and then a fair number ready
thinking about associate's degree so we
got a lot of students that are already
thinking about what's next after high
school okay so what they did was they
asked these students parents educators
counselors about a broad range of
careers we've got education psychology
nursing biology communications
accounting agriculture and then the nice
short little bar here is horticulture
okay even less than agriculture so it
shows that people really are not aware
of horticulture as a career as a degree
program
now this craft takes a little bit of
explaining okay
so this on this axis here is the
percentage and then here are very
various attributes so we have impact
creativity flexibility passion location
of job status compensation job
availability the blue bar is what folks
thought about in terms of horticulture
so they're given a general idea of what
horticulture is and then they're asked
to react to that okay the red line is
what mrs. students the red line is what
students want in their career the
difference the gap between the blue and
the red is an issue we have to work with
other careers don't show this gap okay
other careers the awareness of the
career is much closer to what students
want out of a career so the difference
here in particular passion I know a lot
of very passionate horticulturist trust
me but yet the general public doesn't
view horticulture as being a career one
would get passionate about and a lot of
students wanted a career that they could
really get passionate about so you see
the difference there that percentage is
what we have to work on okay and it was
very clear there was some cases where
this line went below but it was on
characteristics that a lot of students
didn't think were that important so
we've got to increase/decrease that gap
okay the next part of the pastry
research was focus groups bringing
people in and talking with them the six
of these were in urban areas and they
were conducted in person another six
were in rural areas and they were
conducted online with cameras and and
it's very cool how this stuff happens
okay
what became clear from the focus groups
is that dudes really want to do
something that they're passionate about
okay passion has come up multiple times
they want to be creative and they want
to see impact from their work and they
want to do something that makes a
positive impact on the world
it was really fascinating because you
know again I think back to when I was
younger how really advanced in some ways
young people are today in terms of
seeing the world and where they fit into
that and wanting to have an impact even
at that young age okay they want to use
words well we have to use words that
resonate with you the participants liked
sophisticated sounding names you know
and let me talk a little bit about
awareness of Horticulture here okay so
in these focus groups what percentage of
people do you think were aware of
horticultural knew what horticulture was
okay
what percentage so this is a class
question here 15% okay very good other
suggestions 30 a very positive person
very good other suggestions
unfortunately it was zero this is where
they were being asked the word and they
were not being given anything leading up
to it yeah zero well and parents and
teachers now it's a small group because
it's focus groups zero not a one in this
particular groups now we had some
awareness earlier but a lot of that was
where they were people were led into it
you know the components of horticulture
then they were able to put it together
so zero in all of our you know we've had
conference calls regularly or the
steering committee and then later on and
that's a question we often came back to
was what do we do with the word
horticulture because it is clear that
the general public does not know what
horticulture is but if you try to think
about what one word encompasses all that
horticulture is yeah that's a tough
that's a tough question so we finally
just had to stop talking about it
because we kept going down that rabbit
hole and this really these focus groups
really clearly showed that we have an
issue so one of the fun things they did
in these focus groups as they asked
alright so if not horticulture what else
and different categories came up plant
science of course we know that's already
being used plant ology tells me now the
academic in me when I first saw that
it's just like Oh made up word you know
but I have since grown to actually kind
of like that one land arts plant mastery
buying arts I suspect there were some
adults here having to do with wine the
the corresponding part of culture is
plant scientists plant ologist
food and flowers specialists land
artists and plant master okay so one of
the things we susan has done in
workshops is to ask people to take a
moment to think about what they would
call themselves so think about that what
would you Amanda here was calling
herself plant master what would you call
yourself to somebody who has no idea
what horticulture is and is not an
academia so we don't really care think
about that alright
okay so just to summarize real quick
finish up here students want to career
that off is more than a paycheck they
want to be creative and they want to
have an impact okay again creativity
impact so what do we have to do we have
to create a favorable perception of
horticulture and the careers associated
with it okay
parents those who were familiar with
horticulture had a very narrow view of
what it was and what I mean by that is
somebody might have some awareness of
horticulture but they might think it
only had to do with being a landscaper
or only had to do with being a gardener
or a vegetable gardener very few had any
awareness of the breath aboard of
culture from the you know just think
about in the university here we've got
applied science to very basic science
all the various careers that our
students go into you know most people
just do not have awareness of that um
talking about the variety of jobs when
parents are looking into information to
try to help their children out with
careers they cast a very broad net the
Internet educators counselors they draw
in all the information that they can to
help their their their children one of
the things we've got from this is we
need a very robust digital presence
because a lot of time by parents is
spent online researching various careers
and offering suggestions to their to
their their children so we've got a lot
of work to do here
and we have already started on some of
that teachers the summary while some
have heard of horticulture no one
encountered a student who was actually
interested in horticulture now again
we're going back to this fairly narrow
group the focus groups but still that's
that's an issue however once they
learned about it and as I mentioned
before they became very positive about
it again horticulture in and of itself
is something that a lot of people like
once they learn about it and they came
up with a lot
connections that they could see between
the the more general public sort of
activities in horticulture nature and
the outdoors food and cooking health
nutrition science and experimentation
environmental environmental ISM all of
this can be connected to horticulture
and teachers want lesson plans and
activities to help integrate plants into
their curriculum okay and that's one of
the things we're working on we know
there's a lot of information already out
there
FFA for example 4-h has a lot of great
curriculum so what the intent is to be
seen your future be a clearinghouse for
that information and then look for the
gaps and what might not be there we
might have to fill in but at least not
recreate the wheel so guidance
counselor's in middle school guidance
counselor's are actually doing
relatively little in terms of career
they're doing a lot of be the counseling
they're the metrics the sort of thing
they're managing the day-to-day issues
so middle school counselors we have
decided are not going to be a primary
focus okay but I will say high school
counselors they tend to rely a lot on
what they get from universities which is
very nice this came up in some of the
early work and I should have mentioned
back earlier as we were getting into the
information it became clear that we
needed to change our focus just a little
bit going into this the steering
committee we thought that we were going
to need to be focusing on high school
okay what we realized through the
research is that by the time students
are in high school the general path is
set the individual career is not now I
mean I deal with a lot of incoming
freshmen and some of them have a very
good idea what they're gonna do and some
don't but almost always they have a
direction figured out okay what we
realized is that we needed to help
change the direction towards plants in
horticulture and that was going to need
to happen earlier so somebody in hi-c
cool you know they they might you know
they might be narrowing it down to
plants environment biology lawyer doctor
this sort of thing so we decided we
needed to go earlier to start getting
people interested in plants in general
to help set the direction and then the
actual career will come later and
luckily as I mentioned by the time
counselors are in high school they
actually rely a lot on universities we
have a lot of cachet to them because
think about it all the information
that's on the internet you want to rely
on information from universities ok so
overall campaign we want to use words
that resonate we have really learned
that words make a big deal we need to
describe horticulture in terms of impact
food environmentalists you know
environmentalism making those
connections we need to talk about how
horticulture affects that we need to
stress the diversity of jobs highlight
job availability tell the right stories
with the right imagery and give the
tools to the teachers that just sounds
so simple doesn't it we just got to do
that and everything will be better
there's a lot involved with that what's
really nice is I can speak as a former
department head when we started to go
down the path of what to do try to
recruit more students into horticulture
at NC State and it's just such a broad
field and you get half a dozen people
together and all the great ideas people
came up with we were quickly overwhelmed
what the research has done has allowed
us to focus we know that for high school
guidance counselor's for example they
want stuff they want pieces short
one-page pieces they can hand to their
students they can keep a stack on the
desk and just very quickly
not so much videos not so much some of
the other things so we've been able to
target what we need to do for which
group like I said early on I was just we
were getting overwhelmed as to what we
what we could do so how are we going to
make this happen the next step is an
education plan with tools curricula web
resource
partnerships of course in an advocacy
and marketing plan to get all this
information out and that is that's in
progress and there's some of the imagery
right there that's moving forward and
that's going to be the next stage so
with that I'll just kind of did it this
is a video we put together
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
right questions comments this is yeah
it's final for this this phase of the
project the next phase of the project is
really focusing on very specific videos
in fact I think they've got one done
already interviewing folks why they got
into horticulture and what their path
was so at this point it's going to get
more specific and it's going to be
specific videos to help do certain parts
of the campaign oh yeah yes yes yes
clearly a branding issue with with the
neem horticulture yes yeah there is not
an issue with the lack of teaching plant
biology or botany he gets a lot of
education in right now and suddenly
respiration so it seems like the target
while building some lesson plans and
activities is great but getting into
textbooks the name horticulture and
defining that in the textbooks difficult
to do and expensive but it seems like
that's where teachers that's where
students are going to get it that's what
teachers are gonna teach out it exactly
yeah yes that is that's that's part of
the curriculum so these things are going
on if they can use horticultural crops
if they can use horticultural plants and
make that connection yes you're exactly
right that is part of what they what
we're trying to do yeah exactly
no we need to make that connection
exactly right yes Geneva do you have any
questions jump to the the one problem
that you showed so clearly and I'd say
even so we report on the starting
salaries of graduates and various majors
here and horticulture usually looks
terrible in part because a lot of
students will go to a seasonal job or an
internship or something it's their first
job and so the median ends up low as a
result right and that's that's kind of
what people see so that's obviously bad
advertising do you have examples that
you can use of the more room you know
if jobs a horticulture graduate might
get straight out of school that's a very
good question
and we are aware of that and we think
that once a lot of this gets launched
that one of these we're going to need
you to do is to really get a much better
idea of salaries and I can great I need
to rely a little bit on my floor
cultural background one of the magazines
for many years did a release a survey
and it broke out the greenhouse industry
by manager grower s control and that
really did a very good job of splitting
out the various job types and the
salaries and the salaries in those cases
looked pretty good especially for the
manager you know in some of those other
categories what we're seeing is partly
what you're talking about
it's the blending together of
entry-level jobs along with professors
and that sort of thing and business
owners you know when you when you blend
it all together yeah you know the large
number of low numbers from folks that
are making minimum wages on a landscaper
you know working on a landscape crew
really brings down the overall averages
so I think what we need to do there is
for each of the industry is really pull
out the job categories and separate out
entry level which is low I will you know
I will reef 'really admit that but it's
low for most careers entry level tends
to be very low and separate that out
from the higher level jobs and those are
the jobs really that we are training our
students or yes we know that a lot of
you I mean I mowed lawns when I was
young but that's not what I went to
college for I went to college to train
for other kinds of jobs including one
right here in front of you now so we've
got to do a much better job of
separating that out
we don't other than in a few narrow
instances we don't have that data right
now that's a very important thing and
we're doing I'll bet a lot at NC State
the Horticulture Department NC State now
requires an internship
soon to have an internship before they
go out and on a broader scale we've done
a lot of survey work at the College of
Ag level looking at what components of a
resume does industry want or look for
the most and one of the highest scoring
is internships so that shows up a lot so
we do know that internships are
important that is something that we're
trying an NC State to to make it easier
for students to do and yet it also came
up in the seed your future under the
phase one one of the other questions
which I didn't show was we asked
industry what do you think you could do
to help increase awareness of
horticulture and they suggested
internships as well so I think on both
ends of things surprised me because most
horticulturist I know about horticulture
it would seem to be an area to really
emphasize in future videos and
educational efforts to really bring out
the passion that people feel about field
of horticulture
I agree completely and that's one of the
ones that surprised us the most because
we do know so many folks that are just
so into what they do but yet that didn't
come through so a lot of for people not
aware of horticulture just don't know
that we really like what we do and we're
into it and yeah we've got to work on
that
yeah so it seems like there's this
pipeline where you looking undergraduate
enrollment and you're talking about
interstate moisture for our professors
academics what's the thought about
people who work in horticulture but
might not necessarily need to mind a
graduate degree are you guys working to
facilitate any kind of apprenticeship
programs or some other high school yes
and that's a very good point I mean I've
been in land-grant universities I
believe very strongly and what we do but
it's not for everybody
not everybody needs a four-year degree
some folks are a two-year degree is
enough and for some not even a two-year
degree is needed so I you know the we
speak a lot about a pipeline but in a
route we probably need more of a tree
analogy with the idea that people come
in at various points and go out of it at
the point that best suits them so I
would have to say yeah I agree
completely again I'm very Pro University
but some of the students I work with you
know when you sit and talk with them
it's like you really don't need to be
here you know I don't tell my Dean it
but so yeah in terms of apprenticeships
I remember I'm not sure where I'm not
sure that we're specifically working on
it but that would be that would be a
useful thing I think especially early on
like in high school where we might be
able to get folks I think this is a
secure industry it's not getting
outsourced to India
our jobs are staying here comment being
it's a secure industry yes I agree
completely
parts of it might get robots but that's
mostly going to be the entry level not
the not the higher up so I agree yeah
driscoll's whatever yes yeah
thank you all very much I appreciate it
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu